it's been two years since Malaysia
Airlines flight 370 disappeared the
largest and most expensive search
operation in human history hasn't turned
up any helpful clues about where the
plane and its 239 passengers may be or
what happened
you only have one confirmed piece of
wreckage in July of 2015 part of the
Boeing triple7 wing washed ashore on
Reunion Island 450 miles east of
Madagascar
because it spent 500 days floating
around in the ocean all it tells us for
sure is the plane landed in water thanks
Queen flap the near total lack of hard
evidence has encouraged some pretty wild
theories a fire in the cockpit knocked
out the pilots Russian special ops
pulled off a daring air heist scratch
that the military the US military shot
it down and hid the evidence the plane
is in Pakistan nope
you're all wrong mh370 got sucked into a
black hole okay that last one's not
possible but there's no way to know
anything until we find a lot more debris
or the black boxes for the first few
days after mh370 disappeared the search
centered on the Gulf of Thailand in the
South China Sea near the Jets last known
location but satellite data revealed the
plane had flown for hours after that
last communication and was more likely
somewhere over the South Indian Ocean
the other side of Indonesia by the end
of April 2014
eight countries had joined the search
after the initial scramble to find the
plane failed Australia took the lead
based on where the plane was headed and
how much fuel it had they narrowed their
search to a chunk of ocean about 1200
miles east of Australia but narrowed
down doesn't mean much in the ocean now
they were looking for a 200 foot long
plane in the chunk of water the size of
Pennsylvania
if Pennsylvania were 13,000 feet deep
totally dark and had never been mapped
Australia hired Dutch oil and gas
company Fugro to run the 46,000 square
mile search they used sonar to map the
seafloor looking for hazards like
underwater volcanoes by early 2015 new
maps in hand Fugro is operating for deep
tow systems these are basically sensor
pots that get dragged along just 300
feet above the sea floor food rows also
sent out an underwater drone to go where
the tow can by this point the team has
scoured 33,000 square miles of ocean
floor hasn't found any sign of mh370 but
the search hasn't been a total loss
check out this rad 19th century
shipwreck Australia says it by the
middle of this year the full 46,000
square miles will have been covered
and if nothing comes up that's it it
won't expand the search area again but
there are already private groups talking
about picking up in Australia
you